It’s never been possible to predict the
course of an actor’s career years in advance,
but these days, blockbuster franchises can
turn the unlikeliest men and women into certified
action stars.
No one expected to see the lovable Chris Pratt
make the leap from Parks and Rec to the buff
star of Marvel’s Guardians of the Galaxy
and Jurassic World.
But he’s just the latest in the long line
of actors who have transition from comedy
or drama to blockbuster action, and never
looked back.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Unlikely Action
Movie Stars.
Will Smith
The Fresh Prince got his start rockin’ the
house in one corner of his homebase in the
late 1980s before landing his own TV show.
Known more for his comedy skills, he wasn’t
exactly the type of actor you expect to go
see guns blazing against a backdrop of explosions
and mayhem.
But 1995 saw him teaming up with Michael Bay
and Martin Lawrence for Bad Boys, and he’s
kept up his action chops ever since with films
like Independence Day, Wild, Wild, West,
I Am Legend, I, Robot and the upcoming Suicide
Squad.
But no matter what, he’ll always be Uncle
Phil’s troublemaking nephew to us.
Kate Beckinsale
After starting her career in the UK in the
early 1990s, Kate Beckinsale managed to leverage
the exposure she enjoyed in Kenneth Branagh’s
Much Ado About Nothing into roles in films
like The Last Days of Disco, and 2001’s
Pearl Harbor.
But Beckinsale did away with her celebrity
persona to star as the gun-wielding vampire
‘Selene’ in Underworld, a slick Gothic
actioner that ballooned into a four-film franchise.
She hasn’t made a habit of appearing in
many action films since, but seeing her show
up in films like Total Recall always reminds
us she has just as much action experience
as her male co-stars.
Matt Damon
Starring in 1997’s Good Will Hunting – and
earning an Oscar for writing it, too – Matt
Damon was immediately cemented as an award
level talent on the rise.
Roles soon followed in other acclaimed, high-profile
dramas like Saving Private Ryan and The Talented
Mr. Ripley.
But a few years later, Damon decided to try
something outside his comfort zone: the role
of CIA Assassin Jason Bourne.
Today, Damon still A-lists with the best of
them, but when he’s not starring in pictures
like True Grit, and The Departed, he’s more
than happy to sling guns in films like Elysium.
Zoe Saldana
Having practically cornered the market on
mainstream sci-fi these days, with turns in
James Cameron’s Avatar and J.J. Abrams’
Star Trek, it’s tempting to forget Zoe Saldana’s
skills in big screen action, as well.
The Losers and Colombiana didn’t set the
movie world on fire, but the actress showed
how just capable she is when the bullets and
blades start flying.
As Gamora in Guardians of the Galaxy, Saldana
reaffirmed her penchant for playing lethal,
morally grey anti-heroines.
However, her early filmography betrays her
contemporary interests: Drumline, Center Stage,
and a supporting role in Britney Spears’
Crossroads aren’t exactly early indicators
of a late-stage turn toward kicking ass, but
Saldana pulled it off all the same.
Bruce Willis
Bruce Willis is practically the definition
of “action hero” these days, having established
himself as one of the biggest action stars
of all time with the Die Hard series and a
slew of films ranging from The Fifth Element
to The Last Boy Scout.
But Willis’ made his name in comedic films
and TV shows like Blind Date and Moonlighting.
Even after Die Hard 2 hit theaters, Willis
would appear in comedies like Death Becomes
Her and Bonfire of the Vanities.
Today, it’s almost impossible to distinguish
him from his action persona, but there was
a time when the very idea of putting Willis
in such a film would have been laughable.
Nicolas Cage
It’s easy to imagine a world where Nicholas
Cage never starred in The Rock , Con Air,
or Face/Off –instead focusing on more comedies
like Raising Arizona, Fast Times at Ridgemont
High, and Vampire’s Kiss (among many, many
others).
But The Rock secured Cage’s name in the
realm of big screen action above all other
genres.
Even today, he’s sure to show up in the
odd Kick-Ass, Ghost Rider or Drive Angry alongside
indie films like Joe, eclectic offerings like
Adaptation, or thrillers like Matchstick Men.
There was a time when action films were his
bread and butter, but now it’s best to forget
about designations like “action star”
or “comic actor” altogether.
Uma Thurman
Uma Thurman first began her professional career
as a model, but she cut the indelible image
of Beatrix Kiddo into audiences’ brains
at the end of a Hanzo sword with both of Quentin
Tarantino’s Kill Bill films.
Hard to imagine her on the catwalk when she
seemed so at ease lopping off limbs and plucking
out eyeballs.
Yet there was once a time when Thurman wasn’t
a vengeance-fueled martial arts master.
She played Venus in Terry Gilliam’s The
Adventures of Baron Munchausen, and helped
Timothy Hutton get his life back on track
in Beautiful Girls.
No wonder her transformation into a hardened
killer (and desperate mother) for Tarantino’s
violent homage to kung fu and Western cinema
took viewers by surprise.
Keanu Reeves
Starring in Speed, The Matrix and its subsequent
sequels made Keanu a fixture in action cinema
for all time, with his most famous lines as
the mystical Neo now summing up his entire
career.
Before all that, though, viewers knew Reeves
for his laid back surfer dude persona, and
his early history with teen films and dark
comedies.
Reeves didn’t look, act, or sound like an
action hero – but when he packed on the
pounds and shed his hair for Speed in 1993,
he wound up assuming that mantle anyways.
To this day, Reeves continues taking on non-action
oriented projects – like The Lake House,
Side by Side, and A Scanner Darkly – but
hard-hitting action films like John Wick and
Man of Tai Chi keep his action cred intact.
Scarlett Johansson
The once and future Black Widow first drew
wide notice for her talents in another comic
book movie: the low-scale indie film Ghost
World, and earned even more praise years later
for her performances in Lost in Translation
and The Girl with the Pearl Earring.
Johansson started dabbling in action in Michael
Bay’s 2005 film The Island, but in 2010,
she became part of the Marvel family with
Iron Man 2, going from small supporting roles
to blockbuster notoriety.
Now, she’s making a name for herself as
a full-blown action heroine – not only in
The Avengers and Captain America: The Winter
Soldier, but even a starring role in Luc Besson’s
Lucy.
Liam Neeson
This towering Irish actor busted a skull or
two in his day before ever bringing his particular
set of skills to the Taken series, limited
to supporting roles in Excalibur and Krull.
But Neeson defined himself as a dramatic actor
through his work in projects like The Mission,
Michael Collins, and Schindler’s List.
His gravitas was undeniable.
Now, he sports a chip on his shoulder that
fuels his pummeling of European thugs (Taken),
and parachuting a tank out of an airplane
(the A-Team).
It seems that Rob Roy has gone from fighting
English aristocrats to wrestling wolves.
Whatever fueled the shift of genres, it’s
working – and action fans get to reap the
benefits.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any actors or actresses who defied
the odds to become believable action stars?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.